all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel today
I'm gonna be talking about why men
should sleep around
now before everybody before everybody
calls me a grifter and a panderer blah
blah blah I want to talk about how I got
to this conclusion
when I first started reacting and
getting into red pill content this was
something I vehemently disagreed with
and was triggered by I'm sure you could
find some old videos of me speaking
about how why would you encourage
sleeping around for anybody
now you have to understand that men
sleeping around is really a reaction to
women
now we have the top guys right the 20 of
men that just can get laid whenever they
want now a lot of these guys
understand women a little bit better
than the bottom 80 why do they
understand women well they've dealt with
them
a lot of the bottom 80 percent of men
really haven't dealt with women like
that
okay
so
um
now when when we're talking about men in
general
most men are the bottom 80 percent of
men so most men are not getting a lot of
attention from women and when a woman
does give them attention it's like
dear God she can and we've all seen this
in our personal life when a reformed 304
run one ran like runs game on your
brother or your you know whoever
whoever it is some some nice guy
now the reason that sleep
and
please tell me [__] now the reason that
it's good for men is because the more
and I'm not saying they should be
absolute [__] but the more experience
they have with women the more they can
decipher a good woman from a bad woman
and the more men have more options and
sleep around or whatever because
remember the average girl is talking to
multiple men you know let's just be
honest modern women today behave like
men
and so when I first heard this like you
should sleep around I was like
disgusting Haram until I realized that
there's a lot of predatory women and the
only right way that men can pick the
right girl and not be fooled
by a predatory woman who knows how to
come out guys and let's stop acting like
there's just these warning signs that
men can always tell some girls are
really good at putting on a front like
let's just be honest
it's the average guy needs to deal with
multiple women so he can decipher a good
woman from a bad woman and really see
who's actually interested in him because
haven't you ever talked to a dude that's
just like
obsessed with one girl and you're just
like there's more women out there it's
okay
now
yeah so that's that's why
men
should sleep around
um and it's also
to how do they how do they deal with
women in the modern world okay and I
this took me this is a hard pill for me
to swallow because I would hear them
talk about and I would be like what well
I didn't do that wild stuff well it
doesn't matter if you didn't individual
woman because we're not talking about
you
we're talking about women as a group
they're more promiscuous than ever
they're speaking to more men than ever
as a whole so if a man wants to find a
good one
again he has to deal with the multiple
and in order to impress them
he has to be a more of a smooth talker
than ever because otherwise she's going
to go with the guy that's more of a
smooth talker he's gotta be more
accomplished than ever because again we
have act we have social media so now we
have access to all the men right
um otherwise he's not going to be able
to compete
can you blame him
can you blame them I can't blame them
for that this is just a response to us
now the
the the everyone will just say I'm
grifting and pandering and blah blah
blah but I cut because I used to think
like you guys but the more I listened I
was like oh well no wonder
okay well
no wonder they're dealing with us like
this anyways um
okay I think you need a hair tie geez
all right don't make fun of me I'm not I
just learned how to curl my hair so I'm
not very good at it yet but anyways
that's why men it's good for men to
sleep around I don't like it I'm not a
pro that
but
I understand where they're coming from
let me know in the comments I I know a
lot of the conservative crowd doesn't
like this take
but to me men are just solution minded
and the other thing is
if women settled down when we were young
like when you think about it women are
really in control of relationships
nowadays because in the modern world sex
tends to come before relationship now
now I know all the comments will say but
I didn't do that okay but we're talking
about women as a whole society as a
whole
so women are choosing to get married in
their late 20s so now it's harder to
impress them or 30s in the UK and you
know they've been through more they've
done more and
yeah men sleeping around I mean men like
to sleep around I mean that's come on
but but a lot of it is just a response
to the way we act so sorry guys
um You can call me a panda or grift or
whatever all you want this is just the
way I see it
um but let me know in the comments maybe
I'm mistaken I got it all wrong let me
know like the video bye